uh house oversight committee chairman
James comr is now crediting the brave
IRS whistleblowers for holding the
justice department accountable and
forcing them to take action he's 100%
right anyway here with more reaction as
former speaker of the house uh n
Gingrich they said two Brave
whistleblowers Gary shapley and Joseph
Ziegler placed their careers on the line
to blow the whistle on misconduct and
how things have been politicized in the
hunter Biden criminal investigation the
doj got caught in its attempt to give
Hunter Biden an unprecedented sweetheart
deal and today's charges filed against
Hunter are the result of Mr shapley and
Mr Ziggler's efforts to ensure that all
Americans are treated equally under the
law every American should applaud these
men for their courage to expose the
truth IRS whistleblowers also revealed
that investigators were prevented from
following evidence that could have led
to Joe Biden the house oversight
committee's investigation of the Biden
influence pedaling schemes reveals how
Joe Biden knew about participated in
benefited from family cashing in on
Biden's name in fact Hunter Biden's
corporate entities implicated by today's
indictments funnel foreign cash that
landed in Joe Biden's bank account and
unless us attorney Weiss investigates
everyone involved in the Biden's fraud
schemes and influence pedaling it will
be clear that President Biden's doj is
protecting Hunter Biden the big guy your
reaction to that new
Gingrich well look I think at a
practical level um when you look at all
the information what you have is
essentially what I call in a recent
newsletter uh the Delaware
Sopranos uh this is a crime family they
were willing to sell out the interest of
the United States uh as uh somebody said
the other day you now have in effect uh
a CH Chinese Russian paid agent sitting
in the Oval Office uh it's very hard for
me to think that any normal person
looking at the amount of evidence that
every single day gets bigger and
chairman comr has been a part of that um
and has done a good job of digging into
this uh you also have people at the Ways
and Means Committee you have people uh
with Jim Jordan at at the Judiciary
Committee every day something new comes
out and president you're going to have
such an enormous mound of
evidence that it's going to be very hard
for reasonable people uh to not at least
say we need to know what's going on I'll
I'll be very curious as all of this
develops whether there won't be some
Democrats who vote for uh the
impeachment process when it comes to the
floor of the house and I can't imagine
given everything which has been surfaced
uh why any Republican would vote against
remember we're not this is not a vote on
impeachment it's a vote on
investigating and using the system in
order to bring to the surface things
that at least today look like they're
amazingly criminal I I won't repeat all
the details that I gave Professor dtz
but in the case of barisma in the case
of CFC the Chinese oil and gas
conglomerate and the sheer amount of
millions we're talking about and no
experience at all and Joe's direct
involvement in both of those cases with
China the WhatsApp message in Ukraine he
he leveraged the billion dollars to fire
the prosecutor uh I think that's pretty
big evidence that he was involved and of
course the big lie that he told that he
never once talked about these issues
with his son brother or anybody for that
matter that's been blown out of the
water and he made that same lie again
yesterday look there are a couple clear
things here first Joe Biden is a liar
and a crook second there was an amazing
amount of foreign influence pouring into
this country from Kazakhstan Romania
Ukraine Russia China I mean this is
clearly the biggest presidential scandal
in American history in terms of sheer
influence pedaling uh in addition it's
very clear to me at least that they
built an entire structure you have to
say to yourself why would they have all
of these shell companies why would they
have this elaborate system of trying to
hide what was going on we know more and
more that there were all sorts of emails
I saw one report today that Joe Biden as
vice president may have sent several
hundred emails to various people who
worked uh for one of the companies that
Hunter had set up but but here's the
bigger picture you can go around you can
argue about this leaf or that leaf you
can argue about this tree or that tree
but when you see the whole Forest it's
pretty hard to any reach any conclusion
except these people methodically set out
to make money doing things that they
knew were wrong to take money from
foreigners including our major
competitors in the world and then to
methodically lie about it I mean it's
very hard to look at the bigger picture
and not reach that conclusion you know
it's amazing without two Brave
whistleblowers and one Brave judge in
Delaware they would have gotten away
with all of it pretty amazing uh speaker
new kingri thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else